I was very aware that
you know people that I grew up with I'm
not reading those articles you know what
I'm eating yeah and I just felt like who
is talking to these people you know I
mean like
if these people are going to get [__]
over at the very least they deserve to
have explained to them what's happening
you know what I mean but instead you
just get baffled by the stuff on the TV
in the news so um
that's like for me ultimately at his
heart
I think the thing will I believe with
the thing that gives me hope is I
honestly believe if people understood
what was happening here they would not
accept it and we would get changed if
people knew the direction that we as a
society are heading and where we're
going to go
70 80 90 of people would vote against it
and the only reason that
we are able to make Society worse and
worse and worse and worse and worse the
way we are doing is because people are
misinformed and not giving good
information if people knew what is
happening what was going to happen they
were not accept it so